at 25 y'all zendaya's already
accomplished so much i'm such a big fan
i'm so excited to meet a girl i'm she
executive producer author the youngest
person to win an emmy for outstanding
lead
so
i'm just saying i'm such a big fan i i
literally love everything you do you
don't you're not getting your card that
i wrote you because you all ended up you
could come but i wrote you a card i was
just such a big fan of yours and i'm a
fan of y'all as well it's just look i'm
a female she's female i'm like really
enter so anyway so anyway my point is
though is like you've accomplished so
much like so young like what else do you
really want to do do you have like a
list that you're just checking off like
well i just want to say really quickly
me and my mom love you and she wanted me
specifically to say hi to you from her
so mom
i'm a hit with the mom
tell her i said hi
oh my god tell her i said what up
okay okay i will um
i um
there's so many things i mean there's so
many things i would love to do in the
future but i think the most important
thing i think what i try to keep in mind
is you know i know it's kind of a corny
answer but it's like your happiness you
know and prioritizing what makes you
happy and brings you joy and
um
and inspires you and i think if you kind
of chase that feeling then then you
really can't go wrong so i always say
like you know in the future will i be
doing this i hope so because it's what
makes me happy now but maybe something
else will make me make me more happy
maybe there's other things i want to
explore i love directing i i was able to
you know shadow john this whole movie
yeah and watch him work and be
you know and put this incredible piece
of work together which i was nearly
impossible but uh you know every day i'm
learning and growing and i mean there's
so many things i want to do but as long
as i
feel fulfilled and am in doing and then
and am doing things for myself
um i think that you know that's the best
way to do it yeah that's awesome
that's literally like
what i tell everybody that's starting
like enter the industry i'm like don't
chase it like chase what you want like
chasing your dreams that's so important
and that's probably why you're
killing it um so um zinda i actually
wanted to ask you this too so last year
you said you have a heavy responsibility
in hollywood so what what does that mean
to you i feel like we all have our own
like everyone on the couch there and
myself anyone under the spotlight i feel
like you have a responsibility and ours
are all felt differently so what do you
feel like yours is
um
you know i um i was talking about the
other day and and you know i definitely
don't want to be
i don't want people to want to be me so
much as through trying to be the best
version of myself help people
along their journey trying to find the
best version of themselves yeah do you
know what i mean um and i think yeah
i don't you know i think everyone's
path is different everyone's life is
different and it's it's you know it's
hard to compare yourself to anyone else
because there's no other you you are the
best version of who you are because
there's no one else like you
um and embracing that and loving that
about yourself you know that that i feel
like is is my job is you know in a lot
of ways
when i have an opportunity to open
opportunities for others um to make
space for other people um
who don't necessarily have the access
that i've been granted and you know and
try to just do the best i can to help
someone else do the best they can do you
know what i mean yeah absolutely
[Music]
you